you're the type of patient that many of
us doctors are terrified of because
you have a complex medical condition
that we don't fully understand but we
want to feel like we do so we reduce it
to receptors and pills and so on but
we've not seen the full biopsychosocial
thing because it's complicated and we
don't get paid for that we don't have
the time for that we're suffering in a
system that doesn't value connection it
values
throughput and for that reason you're a
challenge to us that
hurts us morally because we want to help
you when we know we can't and so we
don't have the tools resources and
autonomy to do it then
someone like you will then go i need
help so i'm going to go
and find it and then you happen to find
a very restrictive diet that eliminated
most components of the diet that then
allowed you to feel better and for you
that worked brilliantly and
now you have to suffer with having that
same diet all the time which i imagine
you've got used to
not really i'm on freaking like two
foods but like
you don't get used to it it's much
better there's a little bit of me that's
like
that cookie looked really good